you've got your sobriety date in your
social media bio somewhere i think i saw
it so
um i know what that's like
like
one of my um old um
roommates was uh you know he was in a
booze and crack and weed and all that
stuff and you know you you know you
would have thought by the stories that
he told that you know he would have been
this like you know skinny rail you know
like a pinky finger sort of thing but he
was like this fat he was like half
italian half french big ass bad hair
dude like an afro practically he was
just like everywhere total mess and and
he used to uh used to talk about like
his you know those days back in the day
where all the crazy stuff that he would
would do to try to get his hands on
stuff like crack or weed or alcohol
and
he went sober and was like
we used to poke fun on him right you
know because back in our terms would be
like you know buddy might be rolling a
joint and be like hey hey come on buddy
you know you want some of this
he would never budge right like he was
always firm on it which was good for him
because he because he said he would go
to a dark place when he played with the
stuff um were you into crack was it was
it crack was it booze like no no
so yeah man the uh the crack stuff is
just jokes man that's that's you know
how i cope with a lot of the stuff i've
seen yeah because you have to say that
crackheads are like the hardest working
guys out there right for sure you know
explain that you know where i came from
i i remember one day i can't remember
where he was going there's someone my
mom know i know that because my mom is
doing the citizen
and and we we come out we're walking to
the bus stop
and this this junkie comes like
scattering across the court
uh from one of them together just
running working and my mom just looked
at him and shook her head and was like
man that [ __ ] junkie man or she
called crack everything like he been up
for like four days man just chasing a
rock and that that always just stuck
with me like like four days god damn and
then on top of that i had seen like
stuff that i probably should not have
seen
you know we used to be babysit
uh by some straight up like addicts man
they was they were shooting up when we
were around and smoking when we around
in fact one of my earliest memories
i thought uh i we were over at the house
being babysat my mom was coming back
from wherever she was coming back from
and we i picked up what i thought was a
squirt gun and i squirted on the couch
it wasn't 12 was later that i that i was
like oh that was heroin and that's why
it was such a big i was like why is she
so angry about just water like just the
water was going dry and i was like oh
that's because it was it was the dope
and and it was heroin in the syringe
yeah and you know smokes man like why is
this out around kids first of all
um and secondly you know you just
usually get used to seeing that kind of
stuff
and and so i learned to just joke about
it yeah because otherwise you get you
know but what's the old saying man you
could laugh a little or cry a lot i
chose the last round entirely and now
it's just become like a thing that's
still funny to me because people
because because now now it's funny
because so many people follow me and and
a lot of times the way the social media
algorithms work they won't see all of my
posts they'll see you know some self
improvements motivation whatever and
then they'll see me talking [ __ ] about
crackheads i'm like what is this guy all
like and that's why that's funny to me
but as far as what my personal issues
were
i was that was the blues man and and
that was my thing and you know when you
talk about doing whatever you can to get
it
it took me a while to come to terms with
that particular part because because for
me it was just recognizing what got me
sober was recognizing okay this is
really getting it has gotten in the way
of every aspect of my life and i was
just going to precipice of some some
really good things happen and i said
let me put it down let me see how far i
can go and like like when i stopped
drinking my intention was to only do it
for like two years
and then after a year i was like wow man
not only do i have a lot of like like
i've made it far and i've done a lot and
i feel great but i got a lot of issues
and
one of the issues i realized man yeah i
had i have really started like
structuring my whole life my friends my
social life even my my trainee at the
gym i structured it around drinking went
to my coach pointed out that i was
showing up to the gym smelling like
booze that i was like okay that's a
problem
was until people were like got around i
was like he just came over for the
holiday i had a few friends say this and
because i was doing it just going over
going they'd invite me over because i
never spent holidays in my family when i
was younger uh now because i just i
never wanted to be around them
but
i go i drink and then once the blues was
up or i felt like i wouldn't be able to
drive whatever took off uh
pretty much you know
going out every night of the week even
knowing you know i overdraw my bank
account the drink that's that's a bad
sign so there were a lot of bad things
going on you're drinking every day of
the week like drunk
i wasn't well
yeah yeah you know what when i lived
when i could afford it i did yeah
especially because uh part of the part
of the uh
the boxing arc
is that for the last two years of my
amateur career i actually spent it
out in los angeles under this uh this
banner they were trying to build where
they were taking former division one
athletes and turning them into
uh boxers i was not a former division
one athlete by a long shot but i beat
their god they had put a lot of money
into it the national golden gloves he
actually went on to represent us in the
olympics and fought for the world title
twice dominic brazil
so i so i beat him and they sent me out
there and i when they when they brought
me out and i couldn't pass them the
opportunity i was broke as hell at home
and they were they were talking about
paying me three grand a month training
plus rent i said
sold and they flew me out
now i got out there and i have a
driver's license and i don't know if
you've ever been that la you can't live
in that city and have a social life
without a car i mean the public
transport is just not designed plus it's
it's built out wide as opposed to dense
you know it's like four times the area
of new york what a fourth in a
population it's still a big city but
it's it's
you need need transportation so i spent
a lot of time alone on board and here's
what's crazy
back here in pa i live in one of two
states pa in utah whereas the the
liquor is still controlled by the state
so so you gotta go to state we call them
state stores growing up
right chris rock made a joke i think it
was chris rocker dave chappelle man i
don't want to be you know all black
people the same and [ __ ] but uh
he made a joke about you know you got to
prepare yourself when you go to projects
you just look out the window and see
liquor store gun store goes to the
liquor store i didn't get that joke
because i grew up in pa when i first
heard it when i got out to cali
and i could go right over to the target
across the street and pick up a bottle
of some jack or something i was like
what this is crazy so that's what i did
every day after practice i go get a box
of wine
uh well i'd always have a box of mine on
tap but then i go get something to
supplement it like sometimes it'll be a
40 sometimes be a case sometimes it just
be a bottle bottle of jack or a bombay
yeah i was a big fan of bombay sapphire
jen loved uh dirty martini and so i got
to appointment while i was drinking
every day what i could afford it when i
couldn't afford it i just drank cheaper
[ __ ] every day
you know like like i got to appointment
i remember come on but you know
everybody got those signs man i started
waking up with beer on my chest because
i would fall asleep on my back with a
can and i would have it that's why i
would have a rest i'd take a [ __ ] fall
asleep have a sifter on my chest and
then you know you wake up and roll over
around but oh this is crazy
but um
yeah i i had a job at uh t-mobile in for
a little while and one of the things i
used to do on the break
i go over across the street to the bar
and drink or before my shift
always i mean whenever whenever i could
afford to drink that that's what it was
about man and when there was unlimited
alcohol i got a house function that was
the worst man
you know i always find the the topic of
like drinking booze a fascinating one
right it's like you know
the way that you describe it it sounds a
lot like you were
like in
just like a bad drunk right like you
couldn't stop like you didn't have any
self-control
with that yeah that's that's the best
way to put it because i could
oh man cc is hard because i think about
some [ __ ] i did i i i never had that
like oh man i gotta go drink like that
never happened right
but the minute the the pop was topped
you know the top was pop man it was a it
was it man you couldn't stop that that
was me and i had the worst not the worst
personality but but i used to say dumb
[ __ ] like
uh you got to get blackout drunk like
once a week make sure your mind said
it's still on point because you know
your drunk mind is going to tell you the
truth which which now i think is this
when i hear people say i'm like you
understand that's putting you under the
influence it's like a poison in your
brain i'm not saying i'm not
anti-alcohol i'm not talking all for me
right but i'm wrong you know people who
drink all the time i got no issue with
it especially if you're in control you
know enjoy your life but i'm not that
guy you know i can't i definitely
couldn't control it
you